Just two episodes after Game of Thrones gave
Arya Stark a stunning romance scene, the series
completely dropped the ball with another female
character at least in the eyes of countless
fans around the world.
Beware... spoilers are coming!
The fourth episode of Game of Thrones' final
season, "The Last of the Starks," picked up
right after the brutal Battle of Winterfell.
Before Arya Stark vanquished the Night King
and his frosty minions, many good people sacrificed
their lives to protect Winterfell and the
rest of Westeros.
Daenerys Targaryen and Jon Snow attempted
to flame out the enemy with their dragons,
and Brienne of Tarth put her new status as
a Knight of the Seven Kingdoms to use, fighting
the White Walkers as the commander of her
own section of soldiers.
One of those soldiers was the man who knighted
her: Jaime Lannister.
Brienne and Jaime have had a complex history
throughout the run of Game of Thrones.
The pair first met in season 2, when he was
her prisoner.
They eventually grew closer throughout the
course of the series, but they've certainly
had more than a few clashes.
Jaime even gave Brienne his Valyrian steel
sword Oathkeeper for her mission to keep the
Stark girls safe.
Clearly, there's a lot of love between Jaime
and Brienne, but nothing ever came of their
feelings… perhaps because Jaime has been
blindly in love with his sister, Cersei.
That all changed on season 8, episode 4, when
Jaime and Brienne shared an intimate night
together after a drinking game took a turn
for the personal.
The romantic moment was everything you could've
hoped for.
But then, the show took that shiny moment
and tarnished it in a flash.
In the eyes of many viewers, the romantic
scene was ruined just a few minutes after
it all went down, when word got out that Euron
Greyjoy had ambushed Daenerys' fleet and slaughtered
her dragon Rhaegal.
Worse still, news reached Winterfell that
Cersei's minions had captured Daenerys' Handmaiden
Missandei.
Shortly after Brienne delivered the terrible
news to Jaime, he slipped away into the night
to head for King's Landing.
What he plans to do there is a mystery…
but Jaime's departure left Brienne utterly
broken-hearted.
"You're a good man and you can't save her.
You don't need to die with her.
Stay here."
As Brienne sobs, Jaime runs through all the
the horrific things he's done over the years
for Cersei, like pushing Bran Stark out of
a window and paralyzing him for life.
Attempting to show Brienne who he truly is,
he says:
"She's hateful, and so am I."
And with that, Jaime rides off to King's Landing
and Brienne's soft sobs echo through the night.
Fans immediately took to Twitter to express
their distress:
"Brienne crying is something i never want
to see again."
Another Twitter user was evidently having
a breakdown:
"... what should have been our Jaime and Brienne
moment got COMPLETELY RUINED AND I'M SO ANGRY
I WANT TO CRY"
Another fan took aim at the Game of Thrones
writers, tweeting:
"good morning i only came online to say that
brienne deserves better & the writers completely
ruined YEARS of jaime's development…"
One viewer defended the scene, writing:
"[Brienne is] crying because she, more than
anyone, has seen his character growth and
now he's turning his back on that growth.
He's giving up."
Clearly, the Jaime and Brienne romance has
ruffled a lot of feathers.
But there's a potential bright side: Jaime
might be going to King's Landing to kill Cersei.
Perhaps he's planning to return to Winterfell
to live out the rest of his days with Brienne.
Could the Kingslayer possibly become the Queenslayer,
and then become Brienne's new beau on the
next episode of Game of Thrones?
We'll simply have to wait and see.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.